[Music]
on this thursday night
the pandemic spawns another crisis
how many canadians are silently
struggling with their mental health
i was having some pretty dark thoughts i
was having trouble getting out of bed in
the morning
the man who says his cry for help was
rejected
terror in france three people are
murdered at a church
heightened security for america's
election i am concerned about
what happens the threats to democracy at
the poles
and to the people and another hurricane
hammers the gulf coast
plus one of the strongest typhoons to
slam vietnam
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
lots to get to tonight as we track the
spread of kova 19 in canada
but we want to begin with another public
health crisis
that's a consequence of the virus across
the country reports of anxiety
depression
and mental health issues are growing and
there's concern
not enough is being done to help people
who are struggling
this month the canadian mental health
association surveyed more than 1500
people
of those only 35 say the current public
mental health system
is meeting the needs of canadians many
provinces
and the federal government have
committed millions to help tackle the
issue
but an ontario man says he was turned
away
our abigail beeman has his story
i was i was having some pretty dark
thoughts i was having trouble getting
out of bed in the morning
facing extra pandemic stress elliot
hudson knew the warning signs and knew
when to ask for help
and then i discovered beacon his
therapist suggested
mind beacon the ontario government has
provided it nearly two million dollars
to offer free
virtual therapy during covet 19. but
after completing an
intense application he says took him 90
minutes
hudson was turned away beacon is not
equipped to support the challenges of
substance abuse
suicide attempts and more immediate and
critical needs of clients
while hudson has a complicated history
he wasn't in crisis when he reached out
extremely cold impersonal
and discouraging you know to to to get
an email back from
from a so-called mental health
organization that says
you know your problems are are more than
we can handle
that piece hurts because of course
mental illness is a lot about
feeling separate in the world and that
is certainly
you know an invitation to feel separate
shocked to hear the reply hudson's
therapist reached out to other clients
telling them not to apply worried about
the intense application and form letter
rejection
for some of them it could actually have
been
you know fatal mind beacon refused
multiple interview requests for this
story in emailed statements the company
says it is not a crisis service and
points out that message is on the bottom
of its website
mindbeacon said anyone who's
experiencing issues outside quote
listed capabilities is supported in
accessing more appropriate care in their
area
well this is the first i've heard about
it but what i can do is promise the
people
that are having challenges right now
i'll talk to the minister of health i'll
follow up with
the organization that you've said and
we'll be on it because we are a
government that's putting more money
into mental health and
any any time in in the in the past a
promise from ontario's premier
while new data from the canadian mental
health association shows the need is
critical
for many people the situation has gotten
worse
people are feeling more worry more
anxiety and more stress
as the pandemic goes on therapists like
hudson's brace for a tough winter
she's had more calls outside work hours
in the last few weeks
than the last five years combined
abigail beeman global news ottawa
now to the coronavirus crisis and the
situation across canada today
there were more than 2 900 new reported
cases
and more than 40 deaths here's the
breakdown new brunswick had four new
cases today
there were more than a thousand in
quebec and more than 900 in ontario
manitoba set another daily record today
with 193 new infections
saskatchewan also broke its daily record
with 82 cases
alberta had more than 470 and in bc
more than 230. in ontario the number of
new
daily cases remain stubbornly high but
public health experts say
there is some reason for optimism the
spike in infections is starting to slow
a new modeling shows ontario is shifting
away from the worst case scenario
they warn though things can change
quickly
we are still seeing growth we are still
seeing people
sick in the hospital having said that
what we're illustrating is that there
is some slowing of that growth which is
so
important because it speaks to the
efforts that everybody is making
there's a cautionary tale for people
thinking about taking a risk and
attending a large event
a wedding this month in ontario has now
been linked to at least
46 cases the event took place over two
days at a banquet hall north of toronto
in vaughan
public health officials say about 100
guests were in attendance
infections from the event have since
been detected across southern ontario
officials say they're considering
potential charges
france is on its highest security alert
after a suspected terrorist attack at
notre dame basilica in nice
a man armed with a knife killed three
people before being captured by police
president emmanuel macron arrived on
scene and says an
extra four thousand soldiers are being
deployed to protect religious sites and
schools
as crystal reports the attack happened
at a time of heightened tension between
france
and the muslim world and a warning some
of the details may be disturbing
police gunfire at an iconic cathedral
in the south of france
distressed citizens rushed to niece's
nottodam basilica
after hearing that three people had been
killed in a horrific knife attack
reports say an elderly woman was
beheaded
the suspect now in custody in hospital
french president emmanuel macron
expressing support for the catholic
parishioners
saying france stands at your side
islamofascism is how the mayor of nice
described the events
saying france is paying too high of a
price
many are still mourning samuel patti the
teacher was beheaded last week
in an attack supposedly in retaliation
for him showing depictions of the
prophet muhammad to his class
something considered to be blasphemous
to muslims
earlier this month macron pledged to
defend secular values
and crack down on what he called
islamist
separatism normal everyday majority of
muslims as i have said have
have nothing to do with these kind of
radicals luqman ahmed says muslims
shouldn't have to point that out but he
feels they must
he says the goal of extremists is to
alienate muslims from the larger
community
and it doesn't matter if they live in
france or canada
whatever happens in one country does not
stay in one country in this age
due to social media
[Music]
as the sun set in nice people of all
faiths expressed fear about copycat
attacks
the attacker is said to be a 21-year-old
tunisian national who arrived in europe
in september
france's anti-terrorism prosecutor is
investigating
as the terror threat in france has now
been raised to its highest level
crystal comancing global news london
security is top of mind in the u.s in
the final days before tuesday's
presidential election
both the threat of violence at the polls
and the security of voting itself
there is intense focus on fears of
widespread fraud
and intimidation and heightened concerns
about cyber attacks
but as jackson prescott reports
officials are on high alert
the security fence is still up outside
the white house left over from a summer
of unrest
while the rest of washington is quickly
boarding up preparing for every possible
election outcome on tuesday
in cities across the u.s police are
getting ready
let's just be honest 50 50 of the
population is not going to be happy
the security of the vote and of voters
are nagging worries
there's concern about armed poll
watchers disrupting election day
at least five states are considered at
risk for violence from armed militias
like the one that plotted to kidnap the
governor of michigan the department will
continue to plan for any type of civil
unrest
national civil unrest we're thinking
about larger civil unrest either
stemming from
an election result or non-result then
there are the threats both foreign and
domestic that could upend the election
and its aftermath
hackers in georgia have penetrated state
election databases
iran is accused of sending threatening
emails to voters using stolen
registration data
disinformation especially from foreign
governments risks fueling tension
they're going to be really successful if
they can cause people to call into
question the validity of the election
the results of the election an election
in which results could take days to be
delivered
two battleground states have warned it
could take up to four days to finish the
count
it's really important for americans to
understand
that the delay in the final count
is not in any manner shape or form
evidence of widespread fraud it seems
likely the majority of americans will
vote in advance of election day
either in person or by mail any
disruptions on november 3rd could have
an outsized
impact on president donald trump's
campaign because republicans are more
likely to wait until election day to
cast their ballots
robin jackson prosecuting washington
thanks jackson
for months president trump has been
urging his loyal supporters to keep an
eye on the polls
he's claimed the only way he can lose
the election is if the vote is rigged
that's raising fears about how some
supporters might react to the results
fears of violence from right-wing
extremist groups are very real
especially in michigan it's home to a
large number of armed militia groups
and as jeff semple reports they've had a
troubling presence in the state
for decades and you could hear it just
echoing through the entire building
this michigan state senator was sitting
at her desk in the capitol last spring
when she heard the protests
outside each and every one of you
patriots
the crowds angry over the pandemic
lockdown chanted
let us in mcmorrow then looked up to the
gallery to see this
heavily armed militia if one of them
decided to put their finger on a trigger
and start firing
we would be sitting ducks in a fishbowl
and they were taunting us
13 militia members including several
from that protest were later charged
with planning to kidnap the governor i
am concerned about
what happens next and some are preparing
for the worst 2020 has been a bumper
year for gun sales between the months of
march and september
americans purchased more than 15 million
firearms that is nearly twice as many
as the same period last year and nowhere
more so
than right here in michigan people that
are
new to firearms that have no background
to it
they are now realizing that they need to
protect themselves
last year this michigan gun store sold
300 handguns
so far this year they've sold 3 000
across the state firearm sales in
september
tripled freedom being threatened by the
things that are going on
right now yeah these volunteer militia
members
self-styled defenders of the
constitution have existed in michigan
for decades
during the trump administration overall
we've actually seen
what we think is a pretty solid increase
in these groups and in their
members president trump has played in to
many of their fears michigan was hit
hard by the pandemic in the spring
prompting the governor to lock down
businesses in response
trump tweeted liberate michigan hey
governor
let your state open at a rally in the
state this week his supporters chanted
lock her up in reference to the governor
[Applause]
michigan's former republican governor
has heard enough
he's now brought us together he's been a
divider in chief
he's switching sides and endorsing joe
biden
i don't think we need a president that's
actually sort of throwing gas on the
fire
but many trump supporters are steadfast
this republican who joined the protest
at the capitol
says he's counting on the militia to
defend him and
if needed the election all of those guns
you see them all and you're also scared
of them
that's for your protection these
protests and a pandemic
creating a political pressure cooker and
fueling fears that the u.s
is on a collision course with itself
jeff semple global news grand rapids
michigan
big brother at the mall coming up the
millions of images of shoppers captured
without their consent
a major privacy concern to tell you
about tonight involving a dozen
shopping malls across the country
digital images of 5
million choppers were collected using
controversial facial recognition
software it happened without the
customers knowing
an investigation by the federal alberta
and bc privacy commissioners found
cameras embedded in information kiosks
at 12
malls and they gathered information
without consent
that they say contravened privacy laws
the property management company behind
the malls is cadillac fairview
the company says it wanted to analyze
the age and gender of shoppers
not to identify individuals cadillac
fairview says the images were deleted
but investigators found the biometric
information from the images
was stored in a third party database the
malls include toronto's eaton center
calgary's chinook center
and pacific center in vancouver cadillac
fairview stopped using the facial
recognition technology
in 2018. more than ever before
technology is at the forefront of
america's election especially as this
pandemic plays out tonight social media
companies are facing growing scrutiny
and pressure
to prevent a mountain of confusion and
chaos on election night
rob malcolm has more america's tech
giants are bracing for what is expected
to be
an onslaught of misinformation around
election day
and stopping the spread is a major
challenge there is so much false
information out there
on all social media platforms that it's
trying to like put out a forest fire
with a garden hose
social media companies have implemented
new measures ahead of the election
to guard against false or misleading
content the companies have come to the
conclusion
that when it comes to public safety and
what comes to the integrity of the
election
they have to draw certain lines but
where they draw those lines has led to
accusations of bias
twitter's decision to block a
controversial new york post story about
hunter biden
led to a backlash especially among
republicans
thank you very much on wednesday the
ceos of facebook twitter and google got
a grilling
at the u.s center commerce committee mr
dorsey
who the hell elected you and put you in
charge of what the media are allowed to
report and what the american people are
allowed to hear
i hear the concerns and acknowledge them
but
we want to fix it with more transparency
it was a contentious hearing meant to
focus on a law that protects the ability
of tech companies
to moderate content it's a real
difficult situation for these companies
because they don't want to be accused of
censorship
they don't want to be accused of
political bias but at the same time they
don't want false information
leading their members to make bad
decisions based on
rumors that are simply not true facebook
ceo mark zuckerberg says the company
looks to be both
fair and consistent in its approach i'm
proud
that um you know our company and and
as well as the others in the industry i
think have built systems
that are very effective at this but
there are limits to what these companies
can do
and in the end it will be up to
individuals to use
their own judgment i think it's really
incumbent upon
everyone to think critically about the
information
they see and to know where to go for
validation
facebook has put together a war room to
spot election related incidents
twitter says it will flag and label any
posts that misrepresents
election results both platforms have now
banned political ads until after
the election is decided rob malcolm
global news
sacramento still ahead hurricane zeta
brings death and destruction to
louisiana
this is the impact of hurricane zeta it
destroyed a trailer in new orleans
shared the awning off a gas station and
blew a building's wall
open the storm made landfall wednesday
as a category 2 hurricane packing winds
up to 180 kilometers per hour
at least five people have died parts of
north carolina and virginia are expected
to see
damaging winds tonight in vietnam the
worst typhoon to hit the country in
20 years triggered landslides killing at
least 35 people
more than 50 others are missing and
soldiers are frantically trying to hunt
for survivors
the typhoon has damaged more than 50 000
homes and left
millions without electricity heavy rain
is expected in the region
until saturday up next the battleground
state where a unique senator
ditched his democratic dynasty
the trump and biden campaigns are both
paying close attention to the crucial
battleground
pennsylvania and luzerne county has
become something of a poster child for
the state's
swing districts it's one of a handful of
democratic strongholds that surprised
most pollsters
by going red in 2016. global's foreign
nasser spoke to a pennsylvania senator
about why he left the democratic party
to sit as an independent
meet the utics a last name that's been
synonymous with the democratic party in
pennsylvania for a generation
my father a a democratic leader here in
luzerne county for over 60 years
that's where my politics was born that's
the foundation of my politics
but for state senator john eutech 2016
caused a crack
in that foundation which kept growing
you can put
half of trump supporters into what i
call the basket of deplorables
and when you demonize someone because
they go to church on sunday because they
hunt because they're pro
second amendment or they're pro-life and
you demonize that person
and tell them they don't have value
you're not going to get their vote
i felt i no longer could be a democrat
and represent the voice of those
working-class families
now he just had to tell his elderly
staunchly democrat father
he was very proud of my decision and and
with a twinkle in his eye
he said but by god please don't become a
republican until after i die
senator udicek sits as an independent
the only one but his view isn't unique
women and men who feel they were
forgotten turned this historically blue
county red making little known luzern
county
into a national symbol of the discontent
that contributed to donald trump's 2016
victory
joe biden's been outsourcing your jobs
both candidates have been wooing lazerne
biden who hails from scranton in the
county next door held a drive-in rally
last weekend it may come down to
pennsylvania
and in luzerne county politics is a hot
topic
and he paid for what i understand at
least
200 or 300 000 in china you're listening
to fake news
fake news i just go by the facts senator
yudeck is supporting biden but thinks
trump will win
his coveted county vice president biden
is valuing the voters working class
voters
here in luzon county in a way that
secretary clinton did not
and if joe biden wins pennsylvania he'll
be the next president united states
that's what the trump camp fears and
it's why he's holding a massive rally
at the nearby airport monday the night
before
the election farrah nasser global news
washington
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the pumpkin
inferno exhibit near morrisburg ontario
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be broadcasting from washington
tomorrow
and i'll see you on the weekend have a
great night
you